back to what we talked about earlier
about the joyce carol out it does speak
to why she's written so many books it's
that you know it because people always
say to writers is it easy for you to
write must waiters will say no it's the
ability to sit there or to come back to
it i don't think it's always like you
know i mean there are days when just
nothing's going to come no matter what
you do but you have to be willing to
come back now and I think that's where a
lot of people if you're really a writer
if you're really an artist if you if you
if you're not doing it just because
money is on the other end you're going
to come back to it I mean it's
interesting when people come to see me
when they have blocks writers blocks and
to see the different variations I
remember I talked to one writer who said
i don't get writer's block when i'm
writing a script and i get boxed in I
take the last two pages i've written
whatever they are and i throw them away
because no matter how good i think they
might be there what got me into the
corner so i go back in the place where I
wasn't boxed and I keep going from there
I like the deal Simon advice about
writers block which I Keeble I have a
bunch of cards that I keep above my desk
to remind me that I'm out alone and Neil
Simon said he doesn't have writer's
block e as writers dribble he just
writes crap until something good comes
up that's hard to do and that goes back
to what Peter saying about you know
people to just stay there he doesn't
expect everything to be good he just
wants to get something out well I tell
you something interesting I will decide
that I shouldn't start that way yeah
I'll tell him something um now what if
it's really boring and awful well it
will be to you until I explained it
afterward you'll have to draw a diagram
I had a I had a patient come in one day
I said um I've got terrible work habits
and my files are in a total mess and
it's really starting to affect my
business I went well why don't you
organizin he said I don't have the time
I said how long do you think it'll take
he said at least 40 man hours I just I
don't know where I could get the time so
do me a favor try and experiment this
week spend 15 minutes a day organizing
your files tell me how you do he says
that's not worth my time I won't make a
dent I said humor me just so you can
come back and say I told you so so he
comes back next week and says my files
are done said how long did it take you
so I've got three and a half hours one
of the things that happens is when
you're doing a task that's very
effortful that's very difficult you tend
to make an assessment of it and it's a
huge you making it to a huge obstacle
and when you actually get down to doing
it rarely as bad but you feel stupid
saying my files are in terrible shape
but I don't have the three and a half
hours to fix them but 40 is a good
enough number to avoid and he discovered
by spending a little time each day hey
it's actually getting done so what's
jeffrey's saying as much as it hurts me
to agree with them is it's that the
tenacity of staying with it and and not
just it's interesting to me because when
I study people with time management
problems some people have trouble
getting started and once they begin
their okay other people can get started
easily but they can't stay but again if
you make a commitment for even a short
amount of time blue minutes half an hour
every day but I mean I tell people quite
often even if you have to be staring at
the club saying okay eight and a half
more minutes sit there stare at the
clock at least you're down there
somewhat involved eventually some little
breakthroughs happen something comes out
but it's so easy to go back said she'd
last two and half weeks haven't you
looked at that script yeah and guess
what never gonna finish
you